es war eine art leidenschaft ich habe
diese videos geliebt ungefähr vor einem
jahr um diese zeit erschien das erste
video dazu ich erinnere mich als wäre es
gestern gewesen
aber es war vor zehn monaten genau um
diese zeit erschien süßigkeiten braten
teil 1 es gab auch noch teil 2
und zahnpasta braten das war praktisch
teil 3 aber wir sind uns alles sicher es
muss was neues her
also habe ich mich hingesetzt und
nachgedacht es hat mehrere monate
gedauert bis ich auf diese geniale idee
gekommen bin
herzlich willkommen bei ich möchte doch
gar nicht wie es nennen soll es wird
krass und das wird echt lustig und
komisch und so was gab's halt uni und
ich sag mal herzlich willkommen
zu dem ersten part davon ich glaube die
nächsten paar wert aber eventuell
nochmal viel witziger also ich will gar
nicht eingeladen ich wünsche euch viel
spaß also wenn ihr noch mehr davon sehen
wollt last auf jeden fall einen fetten
daumen nach oben da hier muss ich das
jetzt wirklich wissen wenn ihr bock auf
mehr habt dauernd oben wenn ich meint
wegen doch nach unten
wir fangen an sowas geht ich bin jetzt
hier draußen und habe jetzt hier ein
paar
ich fühle mich hier total beobachtet
egal wir sind jetzt auf jeden fall
draußen und wir fangen jetzt
wahrscheinlich was hat er damit vor also
so sachen wie es breit cola oder fanta
kennt ja jeder
das ding ist nur die haben halt immer
diese farbe entweder sind sie halt gelb
dunkel oder einfach so klar und ich war
letztens einkaufen und habe sehr sehr
viele verschiedene produkte gesehen die
waren halt alle nur mit der gleichen
farbe kennt und ihr denkt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon auftakt das kann
auf jeden fall nichts gutes heißt was er
vorhat das kommt gut so ein ich hab mir
nicht hier als gesorgt
und zwar haben wir 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
eigentlich zwingen gekauft war ganz
schön teuer speise farbe ich habe mich
nämlich einfach gefragt ja wie einfach
ist es eigentlich eine cola blau zu
kriegen oder einfach eine blaue cola zu
bekommen ich habe dazu auch mal googeln
ob das vielleicht irgendwie anders geht
nur eine blaue kohle habe ich wirklich
nirgendwo gefunden außer vielleicht so
aus gummi oder so und ich habe wirklich
gar keine ahnung was passiert ich habe
nicht mal ein plan aber wenn ich hier
was rein gebe dass ich da überhaupt
irgendwas verein hatte ich gehe davon
aus aber ich weiß es nicht ich weiß auch
nicht ob das über sprudelt oder so also
die reaktion keine ahnung mein ziel
dieses videos ist aber auf jeden fall
eine blaue cola hinzubekommen und dann
mal gucken wie schmeckt ob die gleich
schmeckt ob die anders schmeckt keine
ahnung wie gesagt hat keinen plan was
passiert ob das irgendwie überschwappt
oder so deswegen bin ich vorsichtshalber
mal nach draußen gegangen ich gehe zwar
nicht davon aus aber wir fangen jetzt
hat der streit an weil ich denke mal
dass da am einfach so übrigens zögern
alle die nach mir noch lebensmittelfarbe
haben wollten
ich glaube zwei gab es noch also leute
schaut euch das an
ich habe jetzt einfach mal rot gewählt
keine ahnung ich hätte auch geld nehmen
können aber wir versuchen es vom brot
[Applaus]
schmeckt auf jeden fall ganz normal so
also ich bin gespannt
also oben ist es wichtig jetzt mal rot
ich bin sofort noch eine hinterher
[Applaus]
das stimmt sogar nach oben alter vater
hatte ich manchmal besser zu das sieht
mega krass aus guck mal das scheint
einfach übels hoch so
ich meine es ist ja kaum aufwand aber
wie das ist doch mega gut für
kindergeburtstage oder so das ist jetzt
einfach gutes breit main wer von euch
hat schon mal rotes bleibt gesehen hier
unten setzt sich das so ein bisschen ab
sich ein bisschen komisch aus aber wir
probieren das vielleicht mal bei der
fanta bin ich eigentlich auch ziemlich
sicher dass ich dir jetzt scheiße was
passiert wenn ich in rente
grün und gelb wird zu hoch
das war ich habe im kunstunterricht
nicht mehr so gut aufgepasst okay leute
ich habe es halt mal gegoogelt hiermit
kann man jetzt nicht so viel anfangen
wir können das aber trotzdem versuchen
das ganze grün zu bekommen also mit rot
zumindest orange werden nur das ist ja
schon so in die richtung orange also
grüne fand alex co leute ich war jetzt
einfach mal zwei klugen gleichzeitig
wollen
[Applaus]
scheiße
wenn ich jetzt grün am mund nehme ich
kann das nicht so gut sehen wie schnell
das geht
grün hey leute guckt euch das an
ich finds cars also meines ist jetzt ja
kein krasser gedankengang so den ich
jetzt entwickelt habe aber rot und grün
dadurch dass man das sieht jetzt gleich
viel gesünder haus so und jetzt kommen
wir zu 1,5 liter flasche cola und diese
cola flasche muss jetzt blau werden ob
wir das schaffen kann ich überhaupt
nicht sagen ich hatte die chance relativ
hoch aber wir werden sehen und hier
knalle ich jetzt wirklich alle acht
blauen farben rein also leute wir fangen
an zu zwei und drei kommen gleichzeitig
so also zwei und drei ist auch drin bis
jetzt erkennt man eigentlich noch nicht
so viel gegenwehr erkennt man noch gar
nichts
also vier stück sind jetzt drin ich habe
jetzt noch die idee vielleicht ein
bisschen mit gelb das ganze aufzuhellen
damit das blau besser zum vorschein
kommen keine aber es funktioniert wir
werden sehen mal wie eklig das einfach
hier oben drauf aus dem es auf jeden
fall kassam scheiben nur irgendwie
verändert sich da gar nicht nur leute
vier packungen habe ich aber auch noch
okay leute die letzte packung gelb
11 uhr wie das scheint aber dann musst
du jetzt mal irgendwas passieren
ich muss das jetzt einfach mal schütteln
es kann gut sein dass es daran liegt ja
also der schaum oben sieht auf jeden
fall gern los
ja wenn man mal so guckt ist auf jeden
fall blau also der schaum ist blau
es sieht eher grünlich aus es ist aber
auch eine menge kohle
ich glaube wer das jetzt 05 für das ganz
anders aussehen zwei blaue packung habe
ich jetzt noch die können dich
eigentlich reinhauen ich will jetzt
einfach mal ein bisschen aus der kohle
herausdrängen oder raus kippen weil ich
glaube so viel schaffe ich jetzt nicht
stellte ja leute kommen die letzte
packung rein hätte glaube ich einfach
mal eine kleinere cola kaufen sollen es
sieht aber echt cool aus nur wir haben
jetzt ein hellblau bzw grün
ich hoffe ihr könnt das gut sind somit
nachdem ich jetzt erst mal gemerkt habe
dass meine zähne ein bisschen grün
aussehen hat mir hier ist dahingestellt
wir haben jetzt hier einmal die fanta
wir haben hier die cola und wir haben
hier die sprite das hier muss man sich
eigentlich im licht angucken
es ist so ein grün violett cola ist halt
extrem dunkel dass ist ein bisschen
schade so ich würde sagen ich mache mir
jetzt meine drinks und das zeige ich
euch natürlich
[Musik]
hey leute ich bin so ein ort ohne nein
wie kann ich so dr ich bin wirklich so
dumm alles guckt euch das mal an
durch diesen scheiß pulli an der ganze
boden hier war einfach rot egal wir
machen weiter so leute endlich habe ich
es geschafft wir haben jetzt hier wir
haben jetzt einmal die grüne fanta die
ziemlich grün aussieht jetzt wird den
eiswürfeln dann die mega geil des breit
war leute schaut euch das an hu das ist
doch was für ein kindergeburtstag
und dann haben wir hier noch die ja also
es geht schon in richtung blau
ich muss mich jetzt auf jeden fall wir
haben vom viertel nach vier und um halb
fünf muss ich nach hamburg waren
deswegen fangen wir erstmal mitdenkenden
schreibe ich meine natürlich grüne fand
habt schmeckt auf jeden fall sehr
erfrischend und genau gleich wie fand
mein mund ist jetzt wahrscheinlich
gerade genau im blick sagte wir kommen
zurück
die schnecke komisch
die schmeckt gar nicht mehr schmeckt
einfach süß aber nur nachts frei also da
ist noch ein bisschen dieser
zitronengeschmack aus aber aber es
schmeckt natürlich trotzdem noch gut und
wir kommen zum schluss zum colat ihr
könnt ihr bei die kommentare schreiben
was würdet ihr sagen ist das für eine
farbe ich würde sagen so violett grün
gibt es das boa das ist mega süß ich hab
da auch einiges rein geknallt aber es
ist echt süß
ich fange ja gar nicht sehen wie meine
zähne aus und über meinen mund
wahrscheinlich komisch das war es auf
jeden fall mit dem ersten video dazu
wenn ihr bock habt dass ich das nächste
mal zum beispiel eine blaue pizza mache
oder so ich habe da wirklich mega potter
aber ich stelle mir das auch super
lustig vor deswegen lässt auf jeden fall
den daumen nach oben da sechs dritte
oder instagram ab wir sehen uns dann am
morgen schon ja ich wünsche einen
schönen tag hat rein